wonder how you would have played Batman
Oh would you have been like I'm Batman
do you change your voice for that or you
know I would have been like I would have
been like I'm Batman know like if you're
hanging a guy by a string right and he's
like hanging upside down and you're in a
bad suit yeah yeah I'd be like who are
you you know and I'm like I'm coming
Batman thanking me is that what you
would have said I'm [ __ ] Batman
wouldn't say [ __ ] cuz it's a 13 right I
really said it would be cold they
believed you you'd be like [ __ ]
Batman is a damn mouth but what do you
mean you would have been you would have
played it like hey I mean come on man
look what I'm wearing it's like yeah but
aren't you trying to scare people as
Batman so why don't you put on an
ominous kind of a I'm Batman
note to self don't have Howard be your
acting coach right yeah I don't know I
don't know what I would do and you know
I will never have that opportunities
maybe you ought to think it through so
you'll get the role of another band man
you know they show a lot earlier I'm
trying to help you at home man